quant à moi c'est d'acheter du papier
hygiénique
ce n'est pas d'en parler ou d'un musée
c'est vraiment achetée puisque je crois
que j'ai conscience aiguë de l'humanité
et c'est lors de l'acte d'achat que se
révèle à moi à mes yeux et aux yeux
d'autrui
la condition première seul qu'on ne peut
pas la condition animale et c'est vrai
c'est lors de l'acte d'achat
alors comment y échapper
on peut économiser le papier ce freinant
soi-même en interdisant ses amis l'accès
à ses propres toilettes en allant dans
les endroits publics pour le volley ou
au travail mais c'est de plus en plus
facile de trouver un travail
je veux au maximum chez les amis dans
les lieux publics mais je délègue
parfois mes amis pour aller en acheter
vous envoler non je l'envol pas parce
que si je m'envolais ce soit il je me
faisais prendre préfère voulait des
livres pornographiques à la limite mais
folie papier jauni que jamais on est
content si je me fais prendre que notre
peu mal contre le domaine du
commissariat
tu seras obligé de te parler devant les
inspecteurs de police de mons vol ne
comprendraient pas
j'allais faire le concept maman moi
j'étais auto rester tout seul avec sarah
et j'ai pleuré tous les gens me
regardaient alors c'est pour ça que j'ai
eu longtemps deux dates où les gens dans
la rue oui et à peut-être sera pleuré
aussi une on a les ailes et en temps de
regarder les vitrines
moi j'étais tout seul moi j'ai eu honte
entre l'âge de 11 ans et 12 ans parce
que je me suis retrouvé tout seul
pratiquement du jour au lendemain dans
une situation très proche de la misère
et j'ai essayé de cacher cette misère je
voulais que personne ne le sache que ce
qui vous faisait honte
massé le regard des autres un jour il ya
un regard qui m'a qui m'a bouleversé
c'était le regard d'un professeur qui
regardaient la fasm en gt habillé et
c'est vrai que c'était c'était j'avais
des d une robe de petite fille de 10 ans
complètement une petite robe à fleurs
ridicule j'avais les chaussures pas
cirer j'avais les ongles sales une
brosse à cheveux j'ai pas ce que c'était
c'était vraiment de la honte où vous
étiez simplement très malheureuse non
non c'était de la honte à ce moment là
c'est j'ai eu honte de moi je me suis
dit mais pourquoi est ce qu elle me
regarde comme ça
[Applaudissements]
moi ma honte c'était mes oreilles je
vais faire recoller j'en ai beaucoup
souffert dans mon enfance
alors j'ai pris cette décision et fo
camarades ont été durs avec vous
effectivement quand on est victime de
quolibets on trouve toujours ça avant
d'entrer duo par exemple tu as de beaux
yeux bleus dommage que tes oreilles les
caches tu payes demi tarif sur voilier
citera viande est entré dans la marine
nationale tu avec un peu de vent tu fera
avancer le bateau enfin ce bon après
quand j'ai fait de la moto bon maintien
tu arrives à mettre un casque de moto
avec les oreilles que tu as vous y
arriviez à mettre le casque
oui enfin en ayant quelques problèmes il
fallait quand même que je prenne soin de
bien plier les oreilles avant de le
mettre sinon effectivement j'arrivais à
avoir des douleurs et dans votre métier
fait vous a posé des problèmes
oui ça m'a posé des problèmes parce que
ce 7e montrent là je veux la camoufler
par une coupe de cheveux assez longue et
ça ne passait pas toujours très bien
vis-à-vis de mes supérieurs
hiérarchiques quand j'étais dans la
marine nationale puisque en fait on se
doit de porter les cheveux courts quand
on est militaire maintenant comment vous
allez vous sentir à beaucoup mieux j'en
suis certain ils ont j'ai eu quand même
une petite appréhension avant
l'opération parce que je savais que
j'allais changer radicalement de look
puisque c'est l'expression consacrée
mais je pense que ça ira beaucoup mieux
pour moi
[Musique]
j'avais honte l'année dernière parce que
j'ai mis un garçon et je lui ai dit là
il l'a répété à la fille qu'il aimait et
cette fille elle l'a répété à toute la
place si tu lui avait pas dit que tu le
mets vins
ça aurait été mieux parce que il aurait
été plus sympa avec moi tu l'aiment
toujours
[Musique]
mahonte s'est passée dans une salle de
conseil général où je vendais une
campagne de publicité à 35 élus sous le
portrait du président de la république
quand on m'a fait passer un petit bout
de papier sur lequel il était écrit
monsieur votre braguette est grande
ouverte
panique générale je veux des simuler je
rougis jeu blêmit je ne sais pas quoi
faire et c'est quand je m'aperçois en
plus dans ma tête et avec mes yeux
également que ce jour là je portais un
caleçon américain qui était lui aussi un
peu trop petit donc la braguette ouverte
et que j'étais en train de parler depuis
un quart d'heure à 35 personnes dans une
salle officiel le bout du sexe dehors
j'avais 11 ans et d'un seul coup ça a
été la honte parce que parce que mon
père était mort et c'est quelque chose
que je n'osais pas dire bon je pouvais
pas dire que mon père et moi j'avais une
monte est formidable don qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient morts quelque chose auquel
je pensais aussi tous les jours bon et
puis je sais pas peut-être je me bats je
me sentais coupable ou responsable mais
je crois que d'une certaine façon aussi
c'est comme ça bon peut-être j'avais pas
fait ce qu'il fallait pour pas qu'ils
meurent bon et donc jamais ou de ça je
l'avais monde du fait qu'il était mort
j'avais honte du fait que par exemple
quand il fallait indiquer la profession
des parents
bon moi la profession' en perse et est
décédé et
ça c'était un truc je pouvais pas
l'écrire - une femme extraordinaire qui
décrit l'enfance je vois les copains du
lycée par exemple certains s'en était
aperçu bon il m'avait dit mais ce but
j'ai regardé dans le bottin et à ton
adresse
il ya pas marqué monsieur et madame ya
marqué selon madame veuve et gesvres
alors là j'avais encore plus puissante
bon parce que c'était si tu es démasqué
je te renvoyer à fait que bon bah je
n'étais pas comme tout le monde j'étais
différent j'étais étudiant en médecine
et j'avais des pulsions j'avais envie de
me masturber et je ne sais pas ce qui
m'était arrivé dans mon enfance ou dans
mon adolescence mais j'avais je croyais
qu'il fallait pas le faire et je ne
pouvais pas m'empêcher de le faire à
chaque fois c'est une lutte et à chaque
fois que je succombe et dire que je me
masturbe et j'avais un sentiment est
épouvantable et ce sentiment
épouvantable se concrétiser par des
migraines j'avais mal à la tête
ce qui m'empêchait d'étudier
correctement c'était l'enfer
c'était une lutte continue à te pleure
je bouffe et de l'aspirine les
médicaments qui me faisait mal à
l'estomac enfin j'en sortais pas et j'ai
nagé comme ça dans la rue sans en parler
à personne enfin jamais j'avais été voir
un ophtalmologiste pour mes migraines
même au nez des lunettes fumées porter
des lunettes non pas pendant cette
période il est très compliqué parce
qu'on trouvait pas grand chose on
comprenait pas que j'étais mal à la tête
je ne disais pas que je me masturbe et
je n avais honte
et quand vous suis combien ça se passait
comment alors annoncé la masturbation se
passer je passais bien ce n'est pas le
problème
c'était après j'aurais voulu pas le
faire j'aurais voulu être un homme
suffisamment fort pour ne pas le faire
alors c'était évidemment un combat
absurde
1 c'était je suis devenu sexologue le
second jour 1 1
un médecin hollandais et le dr md boisse
m'a dit mais ça fait des années que les
hollandais se masturbe sans culpabilité
sans honte ils sont fiers il trouve que
c'est normal j'en revenais pas
monory avait une situation de notables
oui puisqu'il était dans la police faut
dire les ténors la gendarmerie donc en
fin de compte une petite ville on a les
yeux sur lui bon et il a eu une liaison
avec une dame qui avait pas une très
bonne réputation dans la ville en plus
et ça a été une honte pour moi je crois
que j'ai eu honte à sa place et je
voyais bien que dans la rue quand genre
emmener les enfants à l'école quand
quand je faisais mes courses je me
sentais pas à l'aise je sentais on se
retournait sur moi oh ça n'allait pas
alors au bout d'un moment au bon boudin
de deux ans j'ai découvert je trouvais
une lettre un jour on va s'arrêter
c'est encore durer un an alors là
c'était la route complète à ce moment là
ça a été la rente complète parce que je
pourrai plus descendre en ville
cette femme d'abord je dois rencontrer
et puis et puis je vous avais toujours
l'impression que les gens rient vous
c'était peut-être pas vrai en fait
c'était peut-être pas vrai du tout on se
moquait peut-être pas de moi mais
j'avais honte pour lui parce que c'était
quand il représentait quand même la loi
je me disais je lui dise elle a lui jugé
mais c'est pas possible comment peux tu
faire affaire tentons de travail avec
avec la vie que tu mènes en dehors mais
moi je serai des gens je n'accepterai
pas du tout que tu me fasses une
remontrance quelconque je sais pas si
c'est pas possible il était habilité à
les faire des constats d'adultère
comment voulez vous qu'il fasse un
constat d'adultère
moi j'ai eu honte le jour où je me suis
aperçu que ma femme buvais je suis d'un
milieu bourgeois j'exerce une profession
libérale et dans ce milieu
sapers avoir tout d'un coup que la mère
de ses enfants et se vit ce que je
considérais à l'époque comme étant un
avis ou une tare c'était une chose qui
me fallait absolument absolument cacher
monsieur organisé et j'ai organisé ma
vie et la vie de notre couple en
fonction de cette honte qui qui
m'habitait d'une manière pratiquement
permanente c'est-à-dire que je voulais
pas que ça se sache
une fois on a eu un un grand dîner de
fin de stage avec des élèves
il y avait un sénateur qui assisté à ce
dîner te fait par hasard m'enfin il
était là ma femme était assise à côté de
lui elle était ivre morte lui est tombé
dans les bras elle a vomi pratiquement
sur lui donc je géant j'ai embarqué ma
femme à toute vitesse ma fille était là
mon gendre était là on l'a embarqué
jeudi dans des hôtels à un malaise ont
dissimulé
parce qu'on avait on est alors c'est
fini maintenant elle ne doit plus un
jour elle a eu le sentiment que l a eu
la vision de sa de sa déchéance physique
et depuis qu'elle a totalement cessé de
boire il est devenu abstinente et et
sobre c'est de travailler à la sécurité
sociale
c'est une mauvaise image de marque
pisser trop bureaucratique les gens y
sont mal reçue quotidiennes ces sondes
et de vieux bâtiments de vieux meubles
enfin puis on puisse les délais de
remboursement qui sont très longs et
tout ça comment se comporte le collègue
en bail beaucoup voyez on se moque
rigole des gens qui viennent au guichet
parce qu'ils ont des problèmes sociaux
en particulier les gens des classes
sociales défavorisées des chômeurs les
malades mentaux les immigrés tout ça
qu'est ce qui se passe alors au les
baptisant les jo et rigole derrière leur
dos vous voyez quand ils sont partis
or personnellement moi sommes sommes
fait renvoyer si ça me choque
est-ce que vos collègues travaillent
beaucoup on va écouter on voit que c'est
d'or secteur public voyait or ce qui
fait que ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
fait le minimum et ça ça vous fait aussi
peur oui c'est ça oui parce que c'est
vrai les gens les assurés sociaux
ils paient leur cotisation ni normal de
donner le maximum de slam
son travail alors que en plus il ya
tellement de chômage et tout ça il ya
tellement de gens qui voudraient
travailler
or je trouve scandaleux que il ya des
gens qui foutent rien du tout on a même
vu des gens qui dormaient à leur travail
et ça ça vous fait rentrer oui et
maintenant vous avez encore on où ça va
mieux
[Musique]